el comité nacional del paro sostiene sus
propuestas económicas y sociales que
buscan soluciones a la crisis política y
social que ha causado las protestas y se
ha visto agravada por la pandemia de
kobe 19 abanderadas por una renta básica
de emergencia para 6 millones de hogares
en condición de pobreza y vulnerabilidad
por un período de seis meses pues yo
considero que las peticiones que hace el
comité de paro son peticiones racionales
y podemos ver que más de las peticiones
están reflejando lo que es lo que está
pidiendo la la sociedad colombiana en
este momento hay un problema de déficits
sociales que no ha sido resuelto no ha
sido resuelto
durante los últimos 20 25 años que se ha
mantenido una estabilidad macroeconómica
las propuestas tendrían un costo
aproximado de 81 billones de pesos
anuales según cálculos de economistas
locales la mayoría casi 74 billones
alrededor de 23.000 millones de dólares
destinados a la renta básica por ello
los expertos dudan de la viabilidad para
llevar a cabo unas
las económicas tan ambiciosas a la luz
de la situación fiscal del país con un
49 2% de la población trabajando en la
informalidad y más del 42 por ciento de
la población en situación de pobreza
aquí hay que tener también un sentido de
responsabilidad por supuesto que la
sociedad los jóvenes que están marchando
tienen también los derechos para
solicitar algún tipo digamos de ayudas
por parte del gobierno la situación es
muy complicada a raíz de la pandemia la
caída del crecimiento económico el
deterioro del empleo especialmente para
los jóvenes que tienen tasas de
desempleo por encima del 24% pero
también ese tipo de propuestas tienen
que tener esa realidad fiscal en donde
colombia infortunadamente ha tenido
también una caída muy grande de sus
ingresos si bien el presupuesto del
comité está muy por encima de la fallida
reforma tributaria de casi 25 billones
de pesos colombianos
el comité difiere del gobierno de los
economistas tradicionales en la forma de
recaudar los fondos para estas ayudas
sociales proponen que la banca central
haga préstamos la monetización de las
reservas internacionales impuestos a los
más ricos
una apuesta por la producción nacional